ted cruz went to check out the crisis on
our southern border this weekend and the
biden administration does not
want you to find out what he saw
please respect please give dignity to
the people please give dignity to the
people so you work for the commissioner
your senior advisor you were hired two
weeks ago
and you're instructed to ask us to not
have any pictures taken here
disrespectful
because the political leadership at dhs
does not want the american people to
know it please respect the rules you
keep standing
in front of the pictures so you don't
want the pictures taken the rules are
arbitrary and they're designed to keep
the american people
in dignity and respect that's all we ask
you're asking is this dignity and
respect
let me ask you there there's i will
carefully
and your policies unfortunately are
trying to hide them i understand you are
instructed
when 18 senators came down please
respect the people give them
i respect them and i want to fix this
situation
the administration you're working for is
responsible for these conditions please
respect the people with dignity and
respect and i ask
you to respect the people as well i am
respecting you
i am respecting the people this is not
respect that's her story and she's
sticking to it man this
is ted cruz at his absolute best
top of his game that lady wants him to
respect the people not the people who
are crowded at 1500
capacity amid the apparently
extraordinarily deadly pandemic
no she wants you to respect all the
democrats in the biden administration
workers
who have implemented a policy far far
worse than anything they criticized
about trump by michael knows us the
michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday from charles
who writes i need an id to get a library
card but not to vote in american
elections yes this is very strange i
also think this is a good
this is a better point to observe than
to say
you know i need a i need a id to buy a
pack of cigarettes i need an id to buy a
six pack of beer
yeah that's true but those are
privileges and what the left says is
well
yes but voting is a sacred right well
sure but you
you also need id to access any sort of
government service
you need id to travel that's a
fundamental right you need id for all
sorts of things
you get an id the minute you're born you
get a birth certificate you get a social
security
card but but for some reason voting
breaks all the rules why do we have ids
for all these different government
services down to the level of a library
well to prevent fraud to make sure that
that we know who you are to make sure
that the government is not going to
be duped and give certain privileges
and certain rights to people who don't
deserve them
like ineligible voters for instance but
then that goes right out the window with
voting i would yeah hold them to account
on that very good
observation we need a healthy
country we need a healthy republic and
we need a healthy body too that's what i
say not just a body politic but a
healthy body
which is why you should check out
nutrasystem nutrasystem is simple
and convenient with delicious meals
delivered right to your door with little
to no meal prep required that means no
shopping in busy grocery stores
that means that you can lose with
nutrisystem up to 18 pounds
in your first two months the plan is
clinically proven
to put your body in fat burning mode and
helps you achieve safe
and healthy weight loss nutrisystem also
will help you
not only lose the weight but help you to
keep it off they have a top
rated app called nume for extra
motivation to help you stay on track
you get unlimited one-on-one coaching
you can really
sustain this sort of thing a lot of my
friends go on fad diets you know the
ones that are
very popular right now and then they
lose a lot of weight for like two
seconds and they gain it all back
don't do that do it do it the smart way
and do it a way that i think is really
terrific because that nutrisystem
food just tastes great it's really
really great stuff order
nutrasystem now go to nutrasystem.com
knowles know w l e s and you will save
fifty percent off
that is nutrasystem.com
uh really great stuff from senator cruz
i don't say this
only because i host a podcast with a man
named verdict i don't say this just
because he's a friend of mine
this is the kind of thing that a lot of
republican politicians
do not have the kuluni to do and
senator cruz just goes right down and
this woman in the name of compassion she
says
please respect the rights and dignities
please respect the humanity please
respect you're not respecting the
humanity lady
you're keeping these people in terrible
conditions and
worse than that because sure there there
is this problem of illegal aliens who
try to enter our country that that seems
to be
a perennial problem but sometimes it
gets better sometimes it gets worse and
right now your administration
is creating incentives for it to get
much much worse
so now you got 1500 capacity in some
places
amid covid with deplorable conditions
and you accuse ted cruz
of not respecting their humanity because
he shows people
your own corruption because he shows
people the effects of your radicalism
it's like saying saying you might say it
to journalists actually the only reason
that this woman isn't saying it to
journalists they've barred journalists
from actually reporting
on the inside of these centers cruz and
the other senators were able to barge
their way in because they said look
we're
we're a dually elected branch of the
federal government we're going in here
but if not for that we would never see
those pictures
because the biden administration is
being so opaque they want to hide
their corruption and the terrible
effects that it's having on
both the migrants and on the american
republic ilhan omar sees it differently
representative omar wants to stick to
the same story that that
political operative was sticking to when
she was yelling at senator cruz
she's pointing out that the the binding
administration
they are deploying quote maximum
humanity and dignity at the border
what they're looking for right now is to
figure out how the resources they
already have the administration hasn't
asked for new resources
the resources they already have how to
deploy that in the most effective way
to address a problem that was created by
an administration that believed
you had to create
maximum pain in order for immigrants not
to come to our border
and so when you have an administration
now
that says we are going to deploy
maximum humanity and dignity in treating
people
in regards our policies
then we are excited because then we see
partners in humanity we see
partners who see children who are coming
to our country
seeking help
did anything she said mean anything
because she said a lot of words and she
said them very emphatically and she kind
of blew out my eardrum a little bit a
couple of the times
but did that mean anything she may she
makes one factual claim which is that
this problem that biden is dealing with
you know the kids in cages this was
caused by the trump administration
that's just not true to quote our
president who built the cages joe the
cages
go back before the trump administration
ironically to the obama biden
administration
the policy the policy that the left took
the greatest issue with
family separation did not begin with the
trump administration it goes back to the
clinton administration actually so on
that claim it's just completely wrong
then you look at her emotional appeal
she says
we need to give biden a break we need to
actually approve of what biden's doing
because he's doing what he's doing with
maximum humanity and dignity
so what she's saying is the practical
effect of this might be worse than
anything trump ever did
there might be more kids crammed into
more cages amid a pandemic
much worse than anything trump ever did
even by the left's own standards
but the way in which biden's doing it
and more to the point
the motives that have impelled biden
to exert this policy are wonderful and
so we need to
judge biden not by his actions but by
his intentions
which i will remind you about good
intentions uh pave the road to hell
we'll get into the road to hell a little
bit later when we talk about little nas
x who's a rapper but this is a classic
uh tactic of of leftism it's a it's a
tactic of of moral idiots
it's it's a a tactic that uh screwtape
the demon in c.s lewis's excellent
screwtape letters
says to use when he's teaching his his
uh
nephew wormwood how to win over souls
for the devil he says
make sure you always get the human
beings to judge
themselves by their intentions but to
judge other people by their actions to
judge yourself in the best possible
light
and to judge your opponents in the worst
possible light
that's what's going on here i don't i
don't see much
much humanity and dignity at the border
the buying administration right now is
preparing for 800
000 family migrants
so migrants who are coming you know
illegal aliens with
with multiple people in their party in
addition to
the single people who will also be
coming
that that will be a a record
not just for the families but they're
also expecting a record inflow
of unaccompanied children and a spiking
wave
of single men
very bad stuff not not
able to be compared in any serious way
to what happened under trump
my issue is not even to focus on the
numbers and what that means for the
polity for right now
i just want to focus on on these the
moral claims they're making
humane and dignified
many of these people who are getting
into our country illegally
are not tested for coronavirus
the the secretary of the department of
homeland security admitted this just a
couple weeks ago
they're not tested for the virus that
public health officials have told us is
the reason we've needed to lock down and
not see our families and cancel
thanksgiving
and and stop sending kids to school and
cancel christmas
and not let the kids go out and play
we've been told the virus is so serious
that we need to completely suspend our
lives
lock our little american children inside
spiking rates of anxiety
depression and suicide lock american
citizens inside
and yet let foreign nationals who are
untested for coronavirus roam free in
our country
does that make any sense while the biden
administration is pushing for
for practically speaking open borders or
very nearly open borders
with mexico the administration is
pushing for
vaccine passports for american citizens
we told you this was coming it was ever
thus washington post
is reporting now that the biden
administration is considering multiple
versions
of vaccine passports one of the most
significant hurdles facing federal
officials writes the washington post
the sheer number of passport initiatives
underway with the biden administration
this month
identifying at least 17 those
initiatives such as the world health
organization led global effort
and a digital pass device by ibm that is
being tested in new york state
are rapidly moving forward even as the
white house deliberates about how best
to track the shots
and avoid the perception of a government
mandate to be vaccinated so they want to
avoid the perception they don't want to
avoid the fact
they want to avoid the perception just
like they want to avoid the perception
of being
inhumane and undignified at the border
they're not going to avoid the fact
they're going to
keep the trump administration policies
they're going to ratchet them up to 11.
they just want the perception to be
different than the reality and that's
what they're doing
with the vaccine passports by the way
one of the issues with the vaccine
passports
is that they want to make sure that the
passports can track variants
that they can track booster shots so
that the government
and the broader regime buffeted by
corporate power and technological power
and the administrative state and the
educational institutions the whole
liberal establishment apparatus
is going to impel you not just to take
the vaccine
and they're going to track you and track
your medical history but they're also
going to impel you
to get the boosters to get shots for
different variants
and your medical rights such as we have
known them
will erode and erode and erode
this is going to be a a
real touchstone issue here this is going
to be one
that i think separates the wheat from
the chaff you're seeing this debate play
out in the uk right now
and i think you're going to see it here
there are going to be some conservatives
who support the vaccine passports
and they're going to be real
conservatives they're going to be
squishy conservatives who support the
vaccine passports
they're going to be real conservatives
who do not
if you want to stay safe these days
you should check out ring so much is
going on at our front doors
these days that's especially true for me
because i have my sweet little
newborn bundle of joy guess he's not
really newborn and he's two months two
months
of people sending us food people sending
us
a little toys and and clothing and stuff
oh that's all great
and people sending us relatives to come
see our baby now
sometimes you want to open that door
like when it's the pizza outside
sometimes depending on it's that
relative that maybe you know
maybe you don't want to open that door
with a ring you can see and speak to
whoever is at your door whether you are
in your bedroom maybe you are
in your office maybe you are on a beach
on the other side of the world and with
motion detection by the way
you can see who's coming up to your door
even if they don't ring the bell
really makes me feel safe when i'm on
the road and i know sweet little elise
and little june
can know who's outside before they open
up that door it's also a great
housewarming gift
not only because it's a terrific product
but also because it's not that expensive
so you get a lot of credit for a great
gift you don't need to shell out a lot
right now
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kid at ring.com
knowles it comes with rings video
doorbell 3 and chime pro the perfect way
to upgrade your front door
and start your ring experience go to
ring.com knowles
that's ring.com knowles in the united
kingdom right now they are having a
debate
that is coming to america it's
practically here already
the debate is not between the right and
the left but the debate is among people
theoretically on the right and it's
between
it's right now it's being played out
between boris johnson the conservative
prime minister
and nigel farage the brexit leader
another very conservative politician
in the uk boris johnson is
pro-vaccine passport nigel farage is
anti-vaccine passport boris johnson he's
being a little circumspect here but he's
saying that vaccine poor
passports will have some role in the uk
recovering or perhaps not recovering
from coronavirus
farage says no way no vaccine passports
no thank you he said it won't fly
he said it's unworkable and frankly to
put this upon our struggling publicans
at this moment
in time would be completely outrageous
so you're going to see the squishy
republicans
go for the vaccine passports you've
probably seen that already
you you probably know who those people
are the sort of people who call drag
queen story hour a blessing of liberty
those are going to be the kind of guys
who who say that vaccine passports
a-okay
actual conservatives people who want to
conserve anything
you know resembling our
tradition they're going to be against it
and by the way you're going to i think
you're going to see an interesting split
among the the right wingers who are
against the vaccine passports
you're going to see two arguments
against the vaccine passports you're
going to see
the the libertarian argument which is
going to be
about freedom and big government and
that government ain't going to put the
jab in my arm darn it
and fair enough works by i'm not a
libertarian but fair enough
and then you're going to see a
traditional conservative argument
which is going to be focused a little
bit less
on on you know my individual rights and
i've got a natural right not to get
vaccinated or something and it's going
to focus more on
the way that this initiative will upend
our political tradition
our american way of life the idea
i think the traditional conservatives
are not going to say that the government
has no police powers and the government
has no
role in some sort of public health
policy probably the government does and
always has but this is
so radical this is
so foreign to the american way of life
this would so restructure the balance of
power in society
it would give so much more power to the
federal government and to these
billionaire
technological overlords who are going to
be tracking our medical history
and it's going to so reorder our economy
such that
now a handful of people are going to be
able to say are you that whether or not
you're permitted
to engage in commerce it's going to be
so
so radical that we need to oppose it
whatever argument works it's sort of
fine by me we just need to stand against
this
as strong strongly as we possibly can
there's obviously a contradiction in the
narratives that the left is
simultaneously telling us
they're telling us that the virus is so
dangerous that that no one can go
outside we need to live in fear we need
to reorder our society for it
and give the government the rights to
jab us whenever they want
and on the other hand we're being told
that
the virus is so inconsequential that we
need to open the floodgates of our
southern border and let
let unvaccinated often and and often
untested
foreign nationals pour into our country
why because it's that's going to give
democrats an electoral advantage
in the short-term end and especially in
the long term
and and because the the left wants to
erode
the the notion of national sovereignty
and our our current
uh legal system which is which would
enforce my
immigration laws passed by our
representatives who were voted for by
the people in the traditional
constitutional way
they want to replace that with a
technocratic sort of government by the
experts who are not accountable to the
people
uh there's a there's a contradiction
here just on the question of covet is
coveted really dangerous
or is it just not that big a deal right
now the left is is
implicitly telling us both at the same
time because they're changing their
argument depending on their political
point of view but fauci he's sticking to
his story
dr fauci is saying that the the pandemic
is
so bad right now that that your kid
very likely maybe he'll be able to go to
summer camp
maybe he won't you're gonna have to
monitor this situation very carefully
and probably he shouldn't play outside
can they send their kids to summer camp
can they
allow them to play again on playgrounds
you know it is conceivable that that
will be possible margaret because what
we're seeing
is you know as you just mentioned on the
piece we now have
three to 3.5 million vaccinations each
day
if we keep up at that pace invariably
that's going to drive the rate and the
level of infections per day
to a much much lower level if we get
into the summer
and you have a considerable percentage
of the population
vaccinated and the level in the
community
gets below that plateau that's worrying
me and my colleagues in public health
it is conceivable that you have a good
degree of flexibility
during the summer even with the children
with things like
camps we don't know that for sure but i
think that's an
uh an aspirational goal that we should
go for
it is conceivable that if you do every
single
thing i tell you to do in perpetuity
maybe i'll let a little johnny go
outside for half an hour
in the sun it's an aspirational goal
it's an aspirational goal how about we
just do it
how about i'm no expert i don't have
very fancy medical degrees
i think that the kids can play outside
actually i've got some
empirical data here which is since the
beginning
of of the reign of fouchy beginning
last march i've 99.9
of the time ignored everything he said
i've occasionally i've had to acquiesce
because
i need to say travel somewhere on an
airplane and i've made a prudential
calculation and said okay it's better
that i
put the stupid mask on for a second and
fly to this place and give a speech
about how terrible fauci is
then not do that right but that's not
i'm not acquiescing in the sense that i
think he's
he's right i've never really thought the
guy was right uh i've just been living
my life normally and ignoring all of his
dumb guidelines
and uh i'm fine not saying i'm
i couldn't come down with the the
woofloo or something and that would be
that unfortunate and i'm just i'm just
looking at the science here
and the risk is pretty low and the risk
to children
is infinitesimally low so
following the science here it would seem
that the kids can go out and play and
they
should have been able to do that from
the very beginning but what fauci is
making
here is not a scientific argument he's
making a political argument
right she's asking is is it okay for
kids to go play
and he goes look it's conceivable if you
do all this other stuff i want
if we get the numbers what the num what
do we mean if we get the public numbers
down what is the public numbers in
california matter to a kid in new york
if the kid is vaccinated or if he's even
not vaccinated but his parents are
vaccinated
those are specific cases but what fauci
is doing is he's holding
the individual cases as
as an incentive and saying you need to
get the
public matter you you all need to obey
what i'm telling you to do
and then maybe in your individual cases
which are disconnected from the public
matter broadly
then maybe i'll let you and your kids go
out and play
and when i say he's not just talking
about summer camp he's actually talking
about letting your kids go out and play
he says that if you let your kids go out
and play they should wear a mask
yeah the children can clearly wind up
getting infected when we talk about what
you can do when you're vaccinated
you can certainly have members of a
family if the adults are vaccinated
and you're in the home with your child
you don't need to wear a mask and you
can have physical contact
when the children go out into the
community you want them to continue to
wear masks
when they're interacting with groups
from multiple households
now i don't want them to do that
actually so i mean sweet little june
is like two months old now so he's not
gonna go out and see a lot of people but
if i had older children right now
i certainly would not have them wear a
mask i would not listen to anything
that this this power mad sociopath has
to say
i just i just uh don't care the guy has
admitted
to misleading people on on this issue
the idea that anyone
uh uh feels that he still has
credibility is just
patently absurd to me
the the arguments seem always to be
changing
even though the effect is the same
right from the very beginning we need to
slow the spread okay we slowed the
spread we need to flatten the curve yeah
we flatten
the curve well we need to find a cure we
found a cure well we need to
have total vaccine maximum vaccination
okay people are getting vaccinated in
huge numbers
well there might be variants so you got
to keep wearing the masks
well you're going to there's you're
gonna need boosters so you need the
vaccine passport
i i get it if you didn't see what this
was a year ago
some of us hate to say i told you so
some of us did see what this was a year
ago
but i get it i understand how persuasive
the regime can be i understand
how much authority experts in lab coats
hold
in our secular scientific culture
if you don't see it now i don't know
that i can help you
this power grab is never going to stop
unless we stop abiding
the fouchies of the world and all the
other eggheads who want to control
us you know we've got some great shows
coming up
we've got me on the ben shapiro show so
if you if you don't if you feel like
this is not enough uh michael today you
can get get a little bit of me there
because you know ben does this every few
months he tells me that it's there these
ancient
holidays and things like that but i
didn't i'm starting to get a little
skeptical
uh you know every few months i don't
know if i buy it
also uh the candice show is out
uh featured guests have included jaco
willink brandon tatum
john rich country music star who i got
to play guitar with it was very fun
there's some pictures of that floating
around the internet candace is the first
daily wire show to appear in front of a
live audience
but don't worry if you can't attend the
show in person you can tweet your
questions to at
the candice show for a chance to have
candace answer your question at the end
of the night
candace does not shy away from
addressing the truth about a matter no
matter how
controversial she is famously known for
her strong voice in defense
of our country and in support of holding
our culture to a higher standard
the show is available exclusively to
daily wire members so if you're not a
member yet go to dailywire.com
subscribe use candace to get 25 off
that's code candace for 25
off join now so you can tune in friday
night for a closer look behind her hot
takes
check it out at dailywire.com we'll be
right back with a lot more
the biden administration wants to hold
all of us accountable
on the coronavirus and it wants to make
us follow all the ever-changing dictates
of the regime
at the same time the biden
administration does not want to hold
china
accountable china where the virus
started
china which lied about the virus china
which hid
what was going on for months and
according to
early studies that came out last year
may have increased the virality by
something like 95 percent just because
they covered it up and didn't let other
countries prepare
secretary of state anthony blinken going
on cnn now
asked a blunt question do do you think
we should hold china accountable
well i don't know maybe maybe not so
much
you said at your confirmation hearing mr
secretary that you believe the chinese
government misled
the world about coronavirus given that
and the millions of people of course who
have died around the world
should china be punished for that and i
think the
the issue for us is to make sure that we
do everything possible
to prevent another pandemic even as
we're working through this one
uh or at the very least to make sure
that we can mitigate uh in much more
effective ways
any damage done if something happens in
the future and a big part of that
is making sure that we have a system in
place including with the world health
organization
that features transparency that features
information sharing that features access
for international experts
at the start of something like this and
that's where i think china like uh
every other country has real obligations
that it needs to make good on so
i think what we need to be focused on is
making sure we're protecting ourselves
and protecting the world
going forward and that's going to
require a lot of reform and it's going
to require china
to do things that it hasn't done in the
past that sounded like
a no credit credit to
dana bash here who says you know
buddy i'm obviously on your team i'm on
the left
but that was not a persuasive argument
there was a lot of words to say
no the the nearest thing he s
he suggested holding china accountable
was we need
to partner more closely with the who
which is practically owned by china
to to make china be more transparent
even though the wtho partnered up with
china to
hide what was going on in the early days
of the virus pathetic pathetic stuff
but the democratic establishment and joe
biden in particular
seemed to have a real affinity for china
their vision of the world is one in
which china gets lots of special
privileges
and rises up and becomes a significant
power joe biden talked about this
10 20 years ago he said a rising china
is good
for everybody this is why these guys
supported letting china into the world
trade organization not the world health
organization the world trade
organization
a disastrous idea that has imperiled our
country
economically speaking but also as a
matter of security
china caused this virus
the former director of the cdc robert
redfield
believes actually that the flu the
woofloo
came from a lab if i was to guess this
virus started transmitting somewhere in
september october
and wuhan september october that's my
own view it's an opinion i'm allowed to
have opinions now you know i am of the
point of view
that i still think the most likely
ideology
of this pathogen and wuhan was a from a
laboratory
you know escaped other people don't
believe that that's fine science will
eventually figure it out it's not
unusual for respiratory pathogens
that are being worked on in a laboratory
to infect the laboratory worker
can you believe this crazy conspiracy
theorist
uh okay mr redfield please take off your
tinfoil hat sir
you think you think that just because
this
novel coronavirus that
apparently came from a bat was
discovered
like a mile from the wuhan institute of
virology where they were experimenting
on coronaviruses
in bats that maybe that had something to
do with it
it's crazy and excuse me sir what's your
credential what makes you think that
you're
you're uh authorized to pontificate on
these issues
oh just because you're a health expert
and the former director of the cdc
oh wait whoops that goes against the
narrative doesn't it yikes
that doesn't work out anthony fauci who
is the grand poobah of all these
eggheads
he is not so thrilled with what dr
redfield has to say
now redfield because he's a a part of
this club
former cdc director public health
official a fouchy doesn't go after him
as as viciously as he might after other
people
but he he does want to downplay
redfield's
ideas okay so when you think about the
possibilities of how
this virus appeared in the human
population
obviously there are a number of theories
the issue
that would have someone think it's
possible to have escaped
from a lab would mean that it
essentially entered
the outside human population already
well adapted to humans suggesting
that it was adapted in the lab however
the alternative explanation which most
public health individuals
go by is that this virus was actually
circulating
in china likely in wuhan for a month or
more
before they were clinically recognized
at the end of december of 2019
if that were the case the virus clearly
could have adapted itself
to a greater efficiency of
transmissibility
over that period of time up to and at
the time
it was recognized so dr redfield was
mentioning that
he was giving an opinion as to a
possibility but again there are other
alternatives
others that most people hold by but
there are
no don't i can't criticize this guy too
much unfortunately without undermining
my own argument
but uh don't listen to him
okay i don't know doesn't seem again i'm
no expert
i don't i don't wear the white lab coat
but it would seem to me
that there are no coincidences in this
world
and uh particularly those that are that
are so glaring
as as this question of china which we
know was working on these
viruses in bats at the wuhan institute
of virology
notoriously opaque regime that lied
about it and that exerted their
political power over the w
wh to lie about it for months increasing
the effect of this on the world speaking
of a lack of accountability
two teenage black girls tried to steal a
pakistani uber eats driver's car
then as as he was trying to stop them
while he's still sort of half in the car
they took off flipped the car and killed
him
then uh as this man was dying
breathing his last breaths on the ground
one of the young girls
walked right past him back to the the
scene of the crime the flipped car
and she was very upset because she
realized she left her cell phone in the
car
and as the people on the scene said what
are you get back what are you doing she
said no no i i got to get my phone i
left my phone in the car
so that they could walk off the victim's
name is muhammad anwar
if the racial
aspects of this crime were different
this would be international news if it
were two white teens say
and a black driver or perhaps some other
race of a driver this would be
international news this would be
the the left would be blue in the face
screaming about this
as evidence of white supremacy and
how whiteness is corrosive and we need
to abolish whiteness and it would just
all be about white white white white
white
and because the perpetrators of this
crime are black
that's it we're they're going to try to
suppress the story they're not going to
mention race
a race is only ever mentioned and
encouraged to be mentioned
when it suits the narrative that white
people are the perpetrators of
crimes and black people and other racial
minorities are the victims of crimes
very very sad stuff
the left is now taking this further but
it's a point they often go to and saying
that
these girls should not be looked on as
criminals because they're just young
teenage girls
really they're sort of victims we
shouldn't ask how to punish them i saw
various blue check marks tweeting this
uh we shouldn't think about how to
punish them we should think about how to
help them we shouldn't ask
why they chose to do this but what
forced them to do this what compelled
them to do this
i would like to bring together these two
arguments the right tends to focus on
free will and how these how perpetrators
of crimes whether they're teenage girls
or
fully grown adults how they choose to
perpetrate these crimes
and how the left says they don't choose
they're merely passive
figures according to the left now
everyone other than
straight white men or passive figures
and whenever they do anything
or they seem to do anything evil that
really that's just because society made
them do it and by society we just mean
the white patriarchy and that's why
really even when
a racial minority commits a crime you
had prominent left-wingers saying this
just last week
when when a racial minority commits a
crime really it's the fault of white
supremacy
or it can be the fault of white
supremacy so these two apparently
polar opposite arguments that the the
left and the right are making right now
i would like to propose some sort of
reconciliation between them
i get this just reading it a couple
nights ago in the old uncle boethius a
very
very smart writer who was killed
bludgeoned to death
at the end of the roman empire as we
moved into the middle ages he wrote the
consolation of philosophy one of the
greatest books ever written
and boethius describes
punishment justice in a way that it's
sort of
it sounds both super right-wing and
super left-wing in that he says
punishment for crime is an act of
compassion
it's not an act of vengeance or wrath
it's an act of compassion
because human beings seek happiness and
seek the good and seek justice
and when they go down the wrong path it
is a compassionate action
to punish them for that both for the the
injustice that must be satisfied
but also as a matter of sort of
rehabilitation when you punish them
you're
encouraging them to go back down the
right path and boethius then presents
a kind of left-wing argument he says
when when you see people
defendants in court really prosecutors
shouldn't
make an argument about how terrible they
are and that's why they deserve
punishment they should make an argument
about how sick they are
something really sick has gone on with
them and we therefore as a society need
to administer the medicine
of just punishment which is
compassionate
sounds sort of left-wing even though the
left i'm sure wouldn't agree with that
i have no doubt that look
these girls are past the age of reason
so
to some degree they have some
understanding of the moral order and
some control over their will
and they chose to do this horrific thing
commit this horrific murder
and show horrific callousness afterwards
when they cared more about their stupid
cell phone than about the man they had
just killed
also i have no doubt that to some degree
these girls had some weird upbringing
i bet something went wrong somewhere
i'd look i don't know i don't have the i
don't know their family history i don't
know
whether they had a normal stable family
i don't know whether they had a father
in the house i know statistics so i know
doesn't look great i don't know their
schooling i don't know whether they
were brought to church on sunday i don't
know any of these things but
but it would seem to me likely at least
that if you commit this kind of a crime
something went wrong somewhere some
parent failed
and some teacher failed somewhere
probably sure
that is not an excuse to let injustice
reign and to let
these two murderous teenagers off the
hook
they should at the very least be put
away for life i think there's no
no question about that at the very very
least
that is an act of compassion and i think
that when we call for
justice we we can do so in a
compassionate way because
justice is not evil and it's not cruel
it is
good that is what justice is
speaking of evil stuff
i have to get to lil nass x
someone who i didn't know existed until
a few days ago
when he engaged in a satanic publicity
campaign
that that i guess sort of worked because
it caught my attention it caught a lot
of other people's
attention lil nas x who is a rapper
is releasing satan's shoes 666
individually numbered pairs of nike air
max 97s that were modified by the
company
ms chf mischief okay i got it
we'll be they'll be going for over a
thousand dollars beginning
march 29th your mind must be truly
warped by the devil
if you're willing to pay a thousand
dollars for a pair of running shoes but
there are other issues at play here uh
first things first
if you embrace satan who is a real
person
you will burn in hell for eternity hell
which is a real place
we should establish that people are
going to joke about this and say oh here
goes michael he's talking about some
crazy religious stuff i'm not
i'm just bringing you the facts and
facts don't care about your feelings
as my my colleague here loves to say uh
satan is a real person antonin scalia
joked about this when he was talking to
a new york magazine
interviewer a number of years ago she
was she was mocking him for believing in
the devil he said you know
most people in history have believed in
the devil most of america believes in
the devil
many more intelligent people than you or
i have believed in the devil
so don't do that if you play around with
this stuff even if you think it's funny
it's not and you're really putting
yourself in a lot of
uh trouble it's all it's all fun and
games until the devil's eating your soul
for eternity
uh beyond the outrage though is there
something that we can learn
from little nas x is there something
once we once we
tone down the outrage for a second what
is this really saying what can we learn
about this
for our culture i think there's actually
quite a lot there
little nassax is putting out the devil
shoes
that are numbered six six six uh you
know 666 pairs or a thousand dollars
each they include a drop of human blood
in it
not great um he's doing this in
conjunction with a song that he's
releasing
in which he describes his i guess his
sexual desires turns out he's gay and he
came out and he says he's homosexual and
uh where he's like doing like jiggling
around for the devil and giving him a
lap dance and things like that
so i'm going to tamp down the outrage
for a second and say
nike is denying any involvement with
this it would seem that nike's
nike's statement is that the this
company
mischief along with little nass x just
kind of bought retail shoes and then
redesigned them
is that true or not i don't know but
nike's saying we don't want anything to
do with this and no matter
how woke your company gets even even a
company like nike it would seem to be
unlikely that
one of their corporate executives
thought yeah i know the way that we're
going to
make a lot of money we're going to
embrace the devil
and put human blood in our shoes eve i
think that's a bridge too far even for
nike
second of all little nas x is not the
first satanist
in entertainment he's not even the first
popular
black entertainer who's embraced
satanism sammy davis jr
one of the great tap dancers and singers
famous for the rat pack famous
20th century entertainer he was an
actual satanist
for some time he eventually left and he
converted to judaism
but he he joined the church of satan he
actually he
he even made a sitcom pilot
about satanism called poor devil take a
listen
hello furnace room sami speaking sammy
this is chelsea
hi baby you remember the man that you've
been watching
but why don't you keep insisting as a
hot prospect yeah
well i've got him here on the monitor
and you were right
really he's exactly what you've been
waiting for
can you come up right now oh honey if i
come up there now and lucifer catches me
i'm gonna be in all kinds of trouble
oh honey you can't get more trouble than
what you are right now
come on i'm sammy you're right see you
so it it gets even weirder there's
pentagrams in the show and everything
people people don't forget this they
think about the 50s and the 60s they
think oh you know
that time when america you know it had
all this very bourgeois morality and all
these nice suburbs and everything and
you know america's most beloved one of
america's most beloved entertainers was
a
one-eyed satanist who you know
still kind of cuts against a lot of what
we're what we're told
it's amazing because we're told it was
an ableist time we're told it was a
racist time
we're told it was an extremely christian
time and yet one of america's most
beloved entertainers
a black one-eyed satanist he eventually
got out of it though
so obviously they're releasing this now
during holy week we're now approaching
easter
little nassax is doing this for
publicity no question
however i watched the video and i think
the video is actually somewhat
interesting
in the video little nassax is
in the garden of eden and then he goes
up to heaven
and then he goes down to hell he
actually glides a stripper pole down to
hell and starts
twerking on satan's face he is not
condemned to hell
he freely chooses hell and
even beyond that we have to realize that
in the
in the garden he is depicted as being
tempted by the devil
so even that free choice is conditioned
by sin
so you have to ask well how free was he
really to do it you know
you and i we try to resist temptation
and we fail
on and on and on hopefully we get a
little bit better at it but we we still
fail because we're human we have a
broken nature
so it's very interesting here it's not
the judgmental people in heaven
though there are judgmental people
depicted who
force him down to hell he freely chooses
hell
at least in his own mind even though he
has been tempted very clearly by the
devil
is he really free then he gives a lap
dance to satan and then he kills the
devil
and puts the devil's horns on himself
there is nothing new under the sun as
you know and this is not some
new work of art that's come out this is
really in a way it seems to me
a hip-hop modern retelling of paradise
lost by john milton
famous line in paradise lost where the
character of satan is presented in a
sort of sympathetic way
and satan when he's thrust down into
hell
he embraces hell he sort of makes a free
choice for hell
very famous lines he writes farewell
happy fields where joy forever dwells
hail horrors hail infernal world and
thou
profoundest hell receive thy new
possessor me satan
one who brings a mind not to be changed
by place or time
the mind is its own place and in itself
can make a heaven of hell a hell
of heaven what matter where if i be
still the same
and what i should be all but less than
he whom thunder
hath made greater god hear at least
we shall be free the almighty
hath not built here for his envy
will not thrive us hence here we may
reign secure and in my choice
to reign is worth ambition though in
hell
there is a lot here i think actually the
little nass music video
makes a lot of sense in our present
political climate especially with what
the left is pushing
but even with what some portions of the
right is pushing
one of the more provocative elements in
milton's paradise lost
is that satan reads kind of like what
you might call a classical liberal
at least in the way that sort of we
understand that term now
he reads as a guy who who values his
will
and his ambition and his choice
even if he thinks it's a free choice but
maybe it's not a totally free choice
he values that over what is true
and what is good and what is actually
beautiful he says well i've got my mind
so i can make a hell of heaven or heaven
of hell
me me me i'm gonna choose it the reality
doesn't really matter it's just my
mind my will my desires my appetite
that's what matters
this is sure you can have this as a
logical conclusion of leftism
you can have this as a logical
conclusion of individualism too it's why
you're seeing this right now
sort of collapsing on the right the the
of the last 10 or 20 years
it's become fashionable to reduce all of
conservative thought to
i want to do whatever i want to do and i
want to follow whatever desires i want
and darn it that's my right that's
freedom
that's not real freedom none of the
serious thinkers about freedom
liberty have ever thought that certainly
our founding fathers didn't think that
there is a difference between liberty
and licentiousness
you cannot really make
heaven into hell or hell into heaven but
your mind can become
so perverted and so self-obsessed and so
prideful
that you would prefer that you would
feel heaven to be hell
because of that disorder your desires
and your your
perception has become that is the risk
that we're in for society right now
that's why i think actually this little
nast video which is
satanic you know so don't it's bad i'm
not not encouraging it but but it's why
it actually does have something
rather interesting to say about our
politics and hopefully
through providence we can evil things
can can be
turned toward good uh hopefully
we can we can learn some lessons from
this terrible video especially
during holy week it's why it was
released we sing the easter
anti-antiphon we sing
oh happy fault that won for us so great
so glorious a redeemer christians
celebrate
even the fall of mankind which was
which was evil and bad in and of itself
but god turns it to good
and it gives us our great and glorious
redeemer so that's why
we call it a happy fault perhaps we can
we can see these things
that can be turned to good and to take
the that that good turn
uh when we can find it i'm michael
nolances the michael knoll show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021. on the matt wall show we talk
about the things that matter real issues
that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show